hätte sicher folgen stein einbauen
können jol oder was geht hier ist organe
und heute gibt es ein bisschen pvp wann
bis wann mit dem lieben - tut ja ich bin
auch noch am kit mergner problem problem
ich wollte sowieso noch ein bisschen was
erzählen und zwar haben sie ja bestimmt
viele von euch gefragt
christian loose die letzten tage bei max
ich habe ja die letzte an den letzten
vier fünf tagen haben zwei videos
gebracht also so was was ein relativ
untypisch ist bei mir lag daran dass
sich gestern nicht so wirklich bock
drauf hatte da war ich irgendwie da war
es mir wenn ich nach dem video so ich
hatte nicht zu den super tag und so
unter das macht einfach mal kein video
tag davor habe ich eigentlich die videos
abgeschnitten weil die erste wahre
aufnahme und habe ich mich halt da voll
darauf konzentriert war schon mega
aufgeregt so und hab davor noch
trainiert trainiert trainiert und so und
am tag davor habe ich einfach auch
wieder verdeckt so da wird jetzt wieder
ein bisschen ordnung rein kommen also
keine angst das ist auf jeden fall dafür
ist auf jeden fall gesorgt und ja nur
dass jetzt ein kleines update haben wir
kämpfen jetzt zwei files mit dem war
okay zweig oft mit meinem kind und dann
zwei falls mit
ja die kämpfe jetzt erstmal mit dem
barock it-leiter platziert ich habe aber
gar nicht nur weil ich habe gerade
gerade war da noch lava wo ich mein
einmal wieder auf kuba und
wahrscheinlich praktisch ein harter
kampf aber dass ich weiß nicht irgendwo
unterschätzt die lager sowie haben wir
schon ein bisschen ein bisschen gespielt
er spielt einfach lieber mit sms als
mitläufer sagt man immer so hinstecken
man kommt nicht raus hier und die man
viel mehr schaden und bremst aber mit
ernesto weißt du kannst du plötzlich so
machen und dann läuft sogar ein wenig
darunter weißt du du läufst du nein nein
nein nein
city manu ist richtig sodann ist zur
richtigen aufnahme für mache mache
ansage jetzt hast du so aufgebracht wie
lang ja diesmal überraschen dann kannst
du nicht überraschen da muss natürlich
auch aufpassen so wie man am anfang so
seine seine tac toe juncker wie man so
am anfang seine taktiken variiert weil
man halt immer auf dieser karte spielen
man startet jetzt voll unüblicher dass
man so nah beieinander
statt einer klaren 1 schneider 3 block
von reckermann immer was gutmachen kann
zum beispiel auch den anderen weakness
porschen reindrücken am anfang ist auf
jeden fall ganz cool diese wahre
geschichte hier finde ich
er kam immer wieder passend zur hand
nehmen oder vorwärts schwachsinn gewesen
aber die waren irgendwie auch immer oder
die leute haben die sich jeweils ein
bisschen variiert aber ich bin gut
ersetzt dafür auch gewechselt
vielleicht schon ein relativ nah am
normalen war aufwendig also ja ich
glaube die haben wahrscheinlich
irgendwie die elementare von den
letztjährigen waro gewinnen kopiert oder
so was ähnliches
ich bin von mir ein paar mehr später
noch sehr wichtig wenn man so ganz
normal ist das nicht so relevant für
android erst mal da ist aber auch jetzt
habe ich kein wasser einmal bitter ich
hätte was natürlich im zweiten noch im
radio
man muss wirklich das ist ganz anders
als normale steaks oder kommt sie nicht
übertrieben darauf an also klar
letztendlich kommt auch darauf an wer
mehr hits so aber du musst halt viel
mehr auf sachen wie wann man trinkt ich
meine meine passion sowas darauf musste
viel machten so außer sich gewesen aber
man hat ja genug bestimmten server also
allemal genug da ist relativ cool für
mich damit zählen wir die besseren
combos verteilt ich glaube ich liegt er
deutlich vorne
max meinte meine ich jetzt geht's los
stein okay ist der stein ist klang nicht
gerade so nach russland besonders rein
oder so
in europa soll das ok also voll zu tun
herzlich erfolge mit stein einbauen
können walter ich gerade auch im halben
herzen auf die heiligen die hübschen er
voll da das werk bestimmt ich komme da
habe ich immer noch mehr
das ist natürlich auch was wo man was
für daraus lernen kann aber wieder auf
den hype nicht ja 3000 herzen mehr
komplett leise kein anderer so lang bei
mir ich bin bei mir auch ziemlich leise
gestellt das ist ärgerlich dass nach das
okay aber richtig intense auf jeden fall
man kann da wirklich schon spannende
kämpfe ausmachen weil und mit diesem hit
auf hit auf ok taste mich dass wir von
mir angehört bestimmtes paket oder was
ist eigentlich voll vollkommener
schwachsinn habe ich ewig hält
wie konnte ich die töten ich hatte kein
wasser mehr
das war perfekt besetzt wenn du wolltest
wahrscheinlich kein kein trank daneben
weiß nicht dann bin ich halt nicht dran
gedacht wollte dann trainieren der kampf
okay dann fordern wir mit deinem kraus
ja auch es jetzt ein bisschen keine
ahnung standard wie meinst es sogar
relativ ähnlich nur dass nur noch eine
angel drin hast vielleicht natürlich
hier auf ware gibt gedreht aber nur
wenige pfeile finde ich weiß auf jeden
fall soll der held kommt man aber
eigentlich bin ich ganz gut auf einem
ganz guten stand wirklich dachte ich
jetzt mal ein catwalk man habe mir ein
bisschen gefehlt da müssen wir es
einfach durch ist ja auch relevant was
als erstes waren kommt und hatte das
alter wie kann die kannst du das noch
gewinnen
ich hätte dauerhaft ein herz dann hab
ich dir gegeben so heftig ich irgendwie
ewigkeit gewann börse jeweils 1 gegen
feuer versichert ist wir haben beide
jeweils 21
hat man wissen nun meinen porsche aber
von selbst gelöscht ein porsche ein
feiertag eine passion benutzt hat das
letzte mal war schon michael sondern
auch eine creme benutzt
das muss man dazu sagen oh gott jetzt
bringst mich aber auch gott 808 kaufte
ich hätte mein herz handel mit 8,5
hättest du im nacken
ok jetzt habe ich noch mein glück er hat
ja was relativ kurz geworden
arbeiter im prinzip jetzt einbauen und
du kriegst mich nicht mehr aus diese
blogs service pack ist
aber jetzt kannst du da drin ertrinken
nicht zu sechst ein bisschen respekt
niedrig ich habe in der zeit habe es
gegeben als ob du kleiner aspekt wird
und 1224 gehen wahrscheinlich weiter auf
der stelle stehen geblieben bis man berg
oder was einem gerade habe ich in skype
objekt grad ihm was ein bisschen gelegt
so aber dann steht es jetzt 2 32 23 ein
bisschen unfair von mir alles gleich so
deine karte auf kleinsten diesel immer
dieser 1 86 m die nerven und besonders
gas kann ich dort ist ja immer gewusst
auf der karte aber dass so wenige fälle
in deinem kind alter wir kennen
ich habe glaube ich sieben oder acht
zumindest mainz 05 so genau sein ist
nicht schrecklich
ok
okay okay okay ich war viel ok in der
combo die themen die jetzt 42 für mich
eigentlich gewonnen
junge leute früher hat franz ich immer
geschickt ok gerade das war auch ein
bisschen fällig von ihm und davor der
lag aber die combos waren wirklich gut
muss muster zu gehen
deine hier beim war ok taschen lassen
wir ihn gut gegeben auf jeden fall das
stimmt ja das liegt daran werde ich noch
arbeiten freunde wir trainieren jetzt
ein bisschen weiter ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen
nehmen wir noch was für dich auf machen
aber wenn du möchtest du eigentlich
nicht okay dann nämlich nicht verfahrens
ich bin auf dem platz sondern ihr
richtiger fall so dann sehen wir mal
wieder macht gute leute und tschüss